I'm telling you I am giving you who I am
I'm gay I am a creep in sexual cam Tran
stand there come on it up Wow so much
prejudice these days I mean look at this
guy Gloria identifies a heart human
heart mannequin zombie around these
people getting terrified in trying to
shoot him as it whirled so crazy right
now with zombies terrorizing cities a
one-guy iconic rave one or two or three
gallons of human blood without being
immediately judged for it I mean see
this this is why we need more awareness
this is why we need freedom of speech
this this is why I need some be isms so
cabin area of the iron fortress recently
finished airing and in my opinion it
showcases some of the best and worth
attributes of Tetsuo rocky as an anime
director
Tetsuo rocky for those you who aren't
familiar is the director behind such
shows as Death Note guilty crown
high school of the dead and what was
that one show everyone was talking about
a few years ago oh yeah attack on Titan
hey good to know you were pushing back
season 2 to make exactly the same show
you just [ __ ] made you bloody
bail-ins I'm just messin see cabin airy
of the iron fortress and attack on Titan
are totally different
I mean sure some might say there's some
similarities between humanity being
pushed back behind walled cities in fear
of the threat of man-eating monsters
starring a passionate impatient main
protagonist fueled by vengeance who
happens to be a human with special trace
of the monsters they are fighting
complete with a badass female sidekick
who is the real one during the
ass-kicking in the show and don't forget
it screws over its writing halfway
through the show so you see it isn't
really an attack on Titan clone at all
it's a guilty crown clone alright
alright in all seriousness the two
different series in their own rights but
while there are certainly differences in
the themes and directions towards the
end of the series
Carbonari is never quite able to shake
the shadow of its predecessor and then
the end it feels like it was a
lackluster version of everything attack
on Titan was able to achieve I say this
as someone who didn't think attack on
Titan was amazing sure it had some great
moments and was an exhilarating ride
from start to finish but it had plenty
of issues with its pacing and
characterizing which is what stopped me
from putting it up there's one of the
best it was a good anime all things
considered but cabin air II failed to
capture any of the magic it had the
problem basically boils down to two main
factors
and characters it's fear of Japan and
super-powered zombies called Cabana have
invaded the earth so the only way that
humanity is found a way to protect
themselves is by building giant walls
and using weapons that live like the
results of some drunken redneck
experiment that should never work in
real life there are also these people
who are half human half cabana called
cabin re who have heightened abilities
because [ __ ] its anime and god damn if
we're gonna have super-powered zombies
we need Super Saiyans zombie humans to
fight them back its attack on zombies
steampunk Edition and that's fine sure
zombies a cliche but [ __ ] its steampunk
in feudal Japan what's not cool about
that nothing's wrong with a premise
that's been done before as long as it's
executed well but unfortunately it's not
see while in attack on Titan it felt
like humanity was really in a hopeless
situation and that there was little they
can do to fight against the Titan threat
in cabin re while the Kabbani themselves
do actually look at genuinely terrifying
a lot of the danger is simply there from
stupid character decisions that are only
made to find some way to cause chaos for
the story and it's not very surprising
at all when the situation gets [ __ ] do
we take the safe route or shall we risk
the shortcut that takes a much more
dangerous route where nothing can go
wrong
whoopsie-daisy where did this combining
horde come from it's not like how I was
warned about this before coming here
well how about that one episode where
for some convoluted reason we may decide
Oh her name's new made by the way we may
decide to ignore the objective the rest
of her team of working on him goes off
by herself to get some solo kills the
other rescuing don't worry
Alicia got a great K tau dubs bench [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm not playing with you again
it feels like the biggest danger to
humanity on the Kabana
but their own stupidity and it takes
away from any legitimate tension or fear
when you know that the plot is being
moved along by someone's sheer logical
stupidity it feels unnatural and because
of this is hard to care about anything
that happens in the show since
ultimately you kind of think they bloody
deserve it but boys the series try its
hardest to make you care it uses the
same technique seen in the tack room
Titan where the music blares your place
and characters shout in the top of their
lungs every time something dramatic is
supposed to happen it lacks any kind of
subtlety but hey it's an effective
technique I mean how else is the
audience supposed to get hyped up for a
scene if everyone's not
they're [ __ ] lumps off and the music
isn't big and dramatic I mean people are
stupid how are they supposed to know how
some guys can hear me okay and none of
this is helped by cast of is either
bland undeveloped or just plain
unlikable you have cabbage here Erin
miss Kay da that's one he may guidance
on samurai friendzone and god damn go go
to next bug go to the next part of the
video issues with the characters become
more apparent during the second half of
the series when a villain is presented
and a show changes from a fight with
survival type of story into a revenge
plot but instead of adding any depth
into the characters it instead makes
everyone more cliched and the villain
ended up being an unsympathetic
psychopath you had little reason to go
as far as he did to want to well [ __ ] up
the entire world apparently now you may
be sitting there thinking oh man gig are
you ready tearing the show a new one
come on that's not fair it wasn't that
bad it's not fair you compared to attack
and fightin it's his own show with its
own thoughts and feelings and shouldn't
be judged based on appearances because
it's beautiful inside
it's a beautiful butterfly way to spread
its wings let it fly gooo God let it fly
and maybe you're right
that's because seeing a series like this
upsets me it upsets me because there's
obviously been a lot of work and passion
that's been put into this and it shows
visually the series looks gorgeous and
not just because some of the action
sequences are absolutely stunning but
you can tell that a lot of thought has
been put into the look and feel of this
world so much attention to detail has
been put into how the world presents
itself to the little intricacies of the
steampunk technology using the Train and
their weapons the design of each
individual settlement they visit every
character having their own unique style
and quirk of this vintage art style to
the Kabbani looking genuinely terrifying
from start to finish as opposed to giant
making monsters with Down syndrome it
feels like a living breathing world that
could actually exist and something like
this doesn't come along with no thought
put into it the music is also
exceptional the opening theme being done
by the egoist and a soundtrack being
done by Hiroyuki sawano
whether you're bored of sour nosed
bombastic sounding tracks or not he
definitely knows how to make tracks hype
you up to no end and it definitely fits
with Iraqis directing style so with all
that said it blows my mind how a show
which seemingly
is passion an effort from the people
behind it can somehow feel completely
bland and uninspired at the same time
it's an oxymoron this anime is an
oxymoron this girl's not see morrow and
everyone of the show is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
God why is that run of the show so
[ __ ] stupid
so much potential was dropped which is a
huge shame because there's actually a
lot that this show does well and I think
a lot of is down to the director and the
team he works with because this isn't
the first time they've managed to take
something completely bland and actually
make something out of it high school the
dead had no right being as fun and then
painting as it was guilty crime for the
absolute mess in writing that it
contains actually had some scenes that
touched me an attack on Titan would
never have hit as hard if he didn't have
a hand in it when Araki is great at its
being able to make scenes that hits
really hard even if he has no right in
doing so making us care for a second
about characters we really shouldn't
care about or making dumb cheesy action
scenes to do blood pumping sequences I
keep here on the edge of your seat even
we have trashy source material he's been
able to make something out of it but the
problem with cabin air is that it
doesn't do anything new while never
being able to surpass what came before
it there might be some well directed the
individual scenes in it but no death
hits quite as hard no scene quite as
shocking and no fights quite as big as
it stands cabin area of the yarn
fortress feels like a failed attack on
Titan inspired show I know plenty of
people will tell me I should judge the
series based on its own merits and while
some of the themes are different it
doesn't manage to achieve anything that
Iraqis previous work hasn't already done
better even when it tried going a
different direction even if I were to
judge it by itself it would have been a
visually stunning completely average
show but thanks to his writing and
characters dropped its potential to
stand up there with the grace which it
easily could have done with the passion
ours obviously put into it you will
enjoy the show more if you never watch
the attack on Titan well I see no reason
to recommend it over it but now can we
at least take a moment for all the men
who watch this who suddenly came to the
conclusion that oh god the fangirls from
free were right all along back muscles
of sexy Alois are blind
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video a
huge special thanks to Vidal SJP
joseline Adkins Craig Watson
Andrew McClellan and shameless and of
course everyone else who support me on
patreon so I can keep doing what I'm
doing I really hope my pronounce those
names correctly and well you guys wanted
a review and this is what you get kinda
I wanted to distance myself my own
review starts and so I think it's a bit
dated right now and I think it's much
more fun talking about certain aspects
of a show that actually stood out rather
than just sticking to a rigid reveaiing
structure every time so tell me what you
guys think of it but until then I've
been gigging and I'll see you all next
time